la première étape du réservoir presse pour le vol
t moins 15 secondes
dix neuf huit sept
six cinq quatre trois
deux un zéro allumage
décollage il y a une ligne de faucon et un équipage
dragon
go nasa go spacex godspeed
bottom dog amérique l'a
lancé donc
20 secondes après le vol la première étape de
propulsion est  les rapports nominaux
nominaux
maximaux
disent que tous les systèmes vont aux
systèmes malheureusement le
véhicule est supersonique nous avons dépassé
mach 1
[Musique]
maximal nous avons entendu qu'un bravo crie
c'est juste le deuxième
il a fait son travail et ils passent
au second à  ce point
[Musique]
ralentissez,
nous avons entendu dire que nous réduisions les
moteurs merlin lors de la première étape de l'
activité téléphonique et nous avons
confirmé la séparation des étapes miko alpha falcon
[Applaudissements] d'
accord, nous avons confirmé la séparation des étapes
la deuxième
étape depuis environ  caroline du nord jusqu'à
la côte est
presque
autour de là